ça départ 6h15 après la piscine vendredi
c'est cette île un regard quotidien sur
ce planning tristement vides seules
quelques cases colorées pour cette
autocaristes la rentrée catastrophique
logiquement cette période là on a un
planning qui est là qui est tout bleu on
voit là tous les autocars de tourisme à
cette période devrait être sur la route
et aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas du tout
la corse
l'andalousie l'italie où les alpages
suisses tant de voyages annulés qui met
en péril la société familiale
rien qu'en septembre romane charles a
perdu 90% de son chiffre d'affaires en
fait la saison touristique n'a jamais
démarré on n'a pas eu un seul séjour de
l'été mutuellement on allait les
colonies de vacances des pèlerinages en
france à l'étranger cette année par un
donc non l'activité on ne peut plus un
peu plus basse et cas strictement rien
dans l'immédiat
on a très peu de perspectives d'avenir
ici l'activité répartis sur trois
secteurs le ramassage scolaire les
transports de groupes touristiques et
les voyages de classe sans la reprise
des deux derniers volets
froman a perdu plus de cinq cent mille
euros en quelques mois résultat neuf
salariés sont au chômage
trois personnes ne revienne au bureau
qu'à temps partiel impossible aussi
d'avoir des perspectives pour les
conducteurs en activité
en dehors des transports scolaires le
matin le soir et a strictement aucun
autre déplacement même des déplacements
piscine sportifs ou comme on pouvait
avoir avant aujourd'hui on les a pas
donc le conducteur scolaire travaille
tous les matins tous les soirs mais se
retrouve en carence horaire on voit là
on rémunère des heures qui sont pas
effectués à hauteur de plus de 50% dans
aucune case on a déjà mis du temps à
intégrer le plan tourisme plan marshall
comme il l'appelle donc au départ nous
les autocaristes on n'était pas dedans
il restaurateurs les hauts faits des
guillotinés qu'ils ont dit donc voilà
aujourd'hui on a seulement le chômage
partiel
voici une entreprise fonctionne pas je
me dégage aucun revenu et on est on est
en dehors des cases on n'a strictement
aucune haine donc à titre personnel non
j'ai plus 2 j'ai plus de salaire depuis
depuis le début du conflit mais
l'objectif pour l'entreprise relancer au
moins 20% de l'activité touristique
avant la fin de l'année un premier test
a été fait en partenariat avec cette
agence de voyages une excursion au
château de chambord donc une sortie à la
journée mais c'est très très bien
déroulé donc il ya quand même des choses
à faire et à reprendre finalement voilà
le constat il est là si j'ai envie de
créer de produire des journées en groupe
des séjours en gros que j'ai absolument
besoin d'un partenaire autocaristes
c'est essentiel je peux prendre les
inscriptions sur un deuxième spectacle
dans un cabaret à paris donc assez
festif comme on sait pas trop encore ce
que va donner tout ce qui marche et noël
un peu plus perso la pub c'est le type
de rendez-vous qui nous fait du bien
c'est les rendez vous dont on avait
besoin depuis depuis quelques mois ça
commence à reprendre gentiment tout en
douceur
on s'en rend compte mais au moins ça
reprend voilà ça nous donne quelques
perspectives d'avenir donc on en est
plutôt très satisfait une fin d'année en
pointillés et l'horizon 2021 est à peine
plus positif
seuls quelques voyage scolaire se
profile avec ce centre de vacances on
n'a pas de prévisions j'espère que tout
ça bien sûr se fera surtout que
l'inspection académique 10 aux écoles
pour l'instant ne pas trop s'en verrait
ça représente 4 c'est lourd sur le mois
de janvier
le travail de deux conducteurs voilà
donc les 4 août pour qui ce mois de
janvier va être encore encore très
compliqué voilà qui attendent aussi la
reprise rapide pour l'autocariste plus
aucune embauche n'est possible à présent
l'entreprise prévoit même de prolonger
le chômage partiel de ses salariés tout
au long du premier trimestre 2010 21